When you guys wrote songs,
how did you,
how did you put the lyrics to the music?
What was the process like?
How did you guys sort that out?
So you would you come to them with an idea?
Would they come to you with a riff?
Like how,
how would,
how would it work?
It'll work ah,
a number of ways.
But a mistake that a lot of young writers in my department,
the lyrics make is that they think of it as secondary.
Mm.
They wait for the music or the track first and then you'll walk into a studio
and hope that the hand of God will descend and grace you with a amazing
epiphany's.
I can't even spell amazing.
All right.
Um,
and called upon to do it right away.
You know,
you'll work out a beat and go,
Dave,
you got some lyrics.
If I go walk into that room and try to create it right there,
nine times out of 10 it's going to be moon in June,
right?
Moon in June.
Really?
When sometime soon.
What time of day?
I'm thinking noon and literally I'm going to put my hands in the air.
Why?
Well,
cause I just don't care.
You wind up there unless you're banking.
Think like debate.
If you're going to debate somebody,
you're banking your ideas,
right?
Alright.
And whatever the subject is,
you can go,
you don't even have to have this subject itch.
Okay.
I like what he just said.
I might even write that phrase.
I like what you just said.
Could be a Drake lyric.
Any expressions,
ideas,
slogans,
uh,
anything that comes from other tunes in terms of their lyric.
And is everybody contributing?
No,
that's just me.
Just to have volumes of that and those kinds of ideas,
ideas for songs,
storylines,
et Cetera.
You would never go into a fight without doing that.
Collecting moves right from every other film of every other fighter that you
possibly can,
so that when somebody goes like this,
you go,
oh,
I know what to do.
So and so from Muslims.
And then I'm going to visit like this.
And somebody says it's a song about they play a song.
I go,
wow,
it sounds kinda like cowboy music.
Let's ride it back.
Cowboys going through the banking.
Giddy up.
That's cool.
Title.
I heard a cowboy.
I say it on the TV set and I wrote it down literally.
Okay.
And you start bay,
you get,
I see the lights on and you start banking.
Okay.
Somebody says something you dig.
Um,
I heard somebody,
a waitress named pepper
where the unlit pall mall cigarette tell me,
oh honey.
Nothing could have stopped us back then anyway.
Okay.
That's a title.
That is a title.
I wrote a song to it.
Did Ya?
Oh yeah.
Where's this waitress on the road?
Just to,
well she also had some else's say she leaned over,
she showed me that,
that cleavage a little bit and she'd look and she go keep your four Connie.
There's Pie,
excuse me,
I guess.
And you write it down.
Yeah.
Banking.
I like the term they use in debate.
Your banking,
banking,
your ideas.
So when you would go on the road and someone say something that you would
physically write it down,
go home and write it down today.
Today.
All the time.
Bank.
Yeah.
And it goes into the books and then when it's time to deal with a given soon as
you listen to music,
if the music came first and you,
I dunno what's just remind you,
so it sounds like Kung Fu,
that sounds like country,
right?
That sounds like a engines are coming.
It's a and on and on.
It follow you might suggestion idea to write things down physically or do you
type them?
I sh I print.
Print,
yeah.
And I,
I paint and draw routinely.
Okay.
As you know,
as part of the martial arts.
Okay,
sure.
[inaudible] Musashi.
Yep.
But,
uh,
when I was in Japan,
two and three nights a week,
I,
well we call it training.
I did assume Yay.
With a Sumi eight teachers direct Sumia.
It's um,
like calligraphy,
pen and ink in,
in the world of the digital future.
I spent two years practicing four shades of gray and two shades of black.
Yeah.
You want to see my lesson?
Can you do,
can you focus your camera if I stand up?
Yeah.
Can you fucker you,
well,
here's my lesson.
Okay.
I'm going to walk from here to here.
I'm here painting.
Okay.
I'm the only guy in the room.
Ready?
Okay,
here we go.
No.
Yeah.
Okay.
After six months,
I heard better Jesus Christ.
After almost 10 months a shit dad.
He goes,
Mr Rod,
I think you are best student.
Oh,
I should not my painting.
He said,
no,
not.
Your painting said you are most determined.
You are most sincere.
You really enjoy most like this.
Thank you sir.
He said,
I wish to invite you to director's meeting Sumi society.
Whoa.
That's I made the same face.
And I said,
whoa.
I said,
when is that?
He said,
right now and pulled out a bottle of Saki and that's shoe little cups.
Okay.
One of my best friends in Tokyo.
Wow.
First Shit for six sixth,
sixth first six months.
I might've got seven words.
Oh.
For a guy like that,
in this day and age,
it must be insanely difficult to get someone to have that sort of appreciation
for commitment.
Well,
it's,
it's a national thing.
Okay.
You learn that stuff in grade school and it's sorta like music lessons.
Painting and calligraphy is as well known as perhaps piano lessons.
And what were you thinking while you were doing all this?
While you're learning this and spending months and months?
I focus on specifically that,
knowing that at the end of the term,
I'm going to be a little,
I don't know.
I'm sharpening things a little bit and when I'm called upon even to have a
discussion like this,
yeah.
I,
I can bring a little contribution to it.
Yeah.
It can be more entertaining for all of you listening to this.
It can,
you know,
that's an amazing recognition that you have though,
that you realized while you were doing this,
that even though consciously all you're doing is doing calligraphy,
you're working on other parts of your mind.
Oh,
I knew I was never going to pay for shit.
50 shades of Dave.
But you were still focusing 100% of your energy on doing it while you're doing
it.
Yeah.